in this video today we shall do a
comparison of the evolutionary forms of
two godzilla's from different shows
the first one is shin godzilla from 2016
a standalone movie which shows the big g
in a different light
this version evolves throughout the
entire length of the movie
but was scott short before his next
transformation
the other godzilla is the one from the
2021 singular points series
and this too shows similar evolutionary
phases
and that is why we shall compare both of
them side by side
so sit back relax subscribe and let's
get down with this sickness
shin's first form the initial form only
reveals its tale briefly at the start of
the movie
it is huge and in terms of appearance
resembles the second form stale being
yellow-hewed and freight at the end many
water species
are crushed by their own weight if they
attempt to come ashore
therefore the same the original form the
first form of
shin godzilla lacked the physical and
physiological prerequisites to sustain
being on lan
on the concept arts it was supposed to
look like a tadpole with a very long
tail
and under developed arms which kinda
look like
frog legs with fins to help it swim the
tail is reddish yellowish in color while
its back is covered in tan dorsal fins
form one of godzilla singular point a
quarterless
the first form that was seen in godzilla
singular point was
what we all thought it was before it was
a titanosaurus but
it wasn't it was godzilla aquatalus and
it had crocodilian-like physiology
and with a bit of a mix of muscle sore
like characteristics
it featured red violet scales and orange
tail fins as well as an orange stripes
on his back
and pale yellow ridged platings on his
underside
it has huge dorsal spines that go all
the way to the tail
the spines are jagged with vein-like
features that bend
and cone as they travel and the creature
also has four
large web flipper-like legs shin
godzilla's second form well the second
form resembles a more eel
or a thrill shark with a long body a
neck and a tail
as well as stubby underdeveloped hind
legs for land mobility and
stubs on the chest that appear to be
under developed arms
this form unlike godzilla's later forms
has a sickly yellow
complexion which also had red exposed
muscles on his back
and shocked like gills that frequently
bleed indicating that it was
trying to breathe outside the ocean but
it was hard for it to do so
this designs dorsal plates like the
other body components were under develop
too weak to stand up it moves by
wriggling on its belly pushing itself
forward with its stubby hind legs
and also its stubby forelimbs and
trashing its tails
all over the place form two of
godzilla's singular point
amphibia the second form came
immediately after equatless and involved
right after killing the mantas that were
fleeing to land
godzilla amphibia looked a lot like a
varan and a hybrid
or a hybrid between godzilla himself
with a varan when it evolves it still
possesses
three barbs instead of a splat thin like
the previous form
and his hind legs are smaller than his
four legs they have evolved though from
the fins of a cordless
his head is very similar to varen and he
retains a row of godzilla-like dorsal
fins from his aquarius form
although they are framed with a
varanesque spikes on the neck and tail
his back is covered in a knobby scaled
carapace
with these scales also seen running
through his limbs
and also his underbelly is smoothly
textured
shin godzilla's third form godzilla's
third iteration is remarkably similar to
the previous incarnations
this form is bipedal with stronger more
developed hind limbs and the ability to
take a stand
similar to more than godzilla its
forelimbs are
short and its neck is long in comparison
to its body
unlike his second form which possesses a
sickly yellow skin tone
the change in appearance of this form
altered the skin tone as well
to a dark orangey red color with exposed
muscles
changing from a rare to glowing orange
in color
heat may also be observed radiating from
his fins
in this form indicating that this
transformation required a lot of energy
and produce a lot of heat its gills have
also shortened and closed
indicating that it has adapted to
breeding on land despite being bipedal
its legs
have not fully matured causing them to
wobble visibly as it tried to avoid
falling while walking
form number three of godzilla singular
point terrestris
the third form of the strange godzilla
shows a more terrestrial form that
looks more like a dinosaur including the
hunch posture of the t-rex
and the long tail of a carnotaur
godzilla terrestris resembles
his ultimate form but is thin and has a
gorosaurus-like trait
his skin is green with a yellow
underbelly and he has an extended face
with a huge lower jaw
an eye situated quite near to the snout
on his head
godzilla terrestris roars are combined
from the heisei
era and millennium series godzilla's but
when he was struck with missiles he
released the varan
gorosaurus baragon roar it was kind of a
mix of these three kaiju before turning
into a normal godzilla roar
this form also had very unique powers
including tentacles that kind of formed
from his blood
while defending itself from the missiles
and bombs that were
shot at by the humans and it could also
form some sort of a
pre-atomic breath kind of halo that
would
further evolve in the next form
shin godzilla's fourth form while the
final form of the movie
of shin godzilla resembles other
traditional forms in that it is fully
bipedal
and has a fully grown row of dorsal
spines
and is significantly taller than his
previous underdeveloped forms
this formed skin tone is considerably
darker black tone
with red glowing highlights around the
exposed body part such as his neck
back and legs this form's jaw had
multiple rows of jacket
null teeth which protrude in and out
from the skin around his mouth
seemingly litless eyes are also seen and
a jawline that extends widely to the
sides of his head which can also break
into two
additionally the eyes have a brill which
is a protective lens in place of
traditional eyelids that can
protect its eyes from harm and unlike
most godzillas before this one this
godzilla's tail is very long and
consistently hangs around
and above his head inside his tail are
giant human-like skulls
his tail also happens to be where he
spawns multiple
copies of his next evolutionary form
which were never
pumped into action in the movie since
they were frozen before coming out
and lastly form number four of godzilla
singular point which is ultima
well the final form has yet to be
released even in japan well we are all
gonna see godzilla's singular point in
netflix on the 24th of june
my birthday again and so we will shortly
see all of these forms all at once
well as we can see from the trailers it
has a deep charcoal hue
white dorsal plates with red vein-like
patterns flowing through the veins
single point godzilla ultima has a more
monstrous look
there are also a lot of jagged teeth in
the design
in its neck and forearms the creature
contains several osteodome-like
structures similar to those found on
crocodilians
this incarnation has a narrow tongue
many rows of teeth
and tree tubes on the rear of its throat
which
maybe it uses to shoot out the atomic
breath
rather than standing straight it also
has a more grounded like posture like
theropod dinosaurs from way back in the
65th
millionth century and with that we come
to the end of the video
so hit that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the mind cue
family
and one more thing smash that bell
button for regular updates
on monster videos right here on minecube
till the next one take care fam